Treffpunkt hier finden Sie da Platz was
ihr Gesellschaft Teil verloren
zwei Jahren bin ich auf jeden Mann Komma
danke die Mannschaft
und was geht denn er Hoffnung
[Musik]
vom ersten Teil abgeschlossen
im fortgeschrittenen Stadium und da sie
schlafen
Süchtigen
abgestürzt vor vier Jahren ist sie
wegkommen
und ihrem Körper Pause gegangen
einfach langweilig
also
einfach alleine
auf Naht gut aber der App auf NATO
schlecht für mich
macht es Angst
diskutieren
[Musik]
mit berührt und ich wünsche euch Kraft
auf der Welt dass sie
zu der weiß es doch
[Musik]
zwei Wochen später fahre ich zum
jackpunkte
[Musik]
Tobias schon gut gelungen
schaffen
und keine Ahnung hallo
[Musik]
im Nachhinein dankbar dafür
deutsche
[Musik]
ja perfekt
ja
[Musik]
Checkpoint so aber mir schon nicht die
normale Gesellschaft
doch der Versand ist 140
[Musik]
Checkpunkt
ambulante Therapie irgendwie
schon wochenkalieren
[Musik]
bitte mal auf dem Weg ist Checkpunkt und
für Transgen wir schöne kreisschliessen
hallo hi
Tomi hallo
30 Jahre hätte bei einem Autounfall
seine Freundin verloren wo schwanger ist
mit Herten abgestürzt wie Dana hat der
Thomson
professionell betreut wird
die letzten 1800
wurde
im vertraut
ja mit dem können viel Spaß haben
mich begleitet wie sehr schwere Zeit
macht haben eine Beziehung genau
[Musik]
[Applaus]
muss wieder sehen kraftfinger
Integration und Gesellschaft
Pipapo aber das ist Mini Schablone
suchtberaterinnen und Experten können
Strukturen die neuronale
Veränderung
und mit einer Suchtverhalten
das gleiche Verhalten machen wir die
vorher die Spuren
24 Stunden
Garage
[Musik]
[Applaus]
die Wertlosigkeit
aber sie aus Verein sie und drücken
Perspektive und ja
Aktionen
Kommentar Frage
Protagonistin tschüss